liv est déjà montée est prête à bois
vert et andré paul hus travail chez
urgences-santé
mais ce ne sont pas des techniciens
ambulanciers comme les autres ils sont
ce qu'on appelle des ambulanciers
paramédicaux en soins avancés
ils interviennent seul ou accompagné
premiers répondants et techniciens
ambulanciers
il répond seulement vous appel lorsqu'il
ya un danger pour la vie dans le jargon
du métier les appels de priorité 0 ou 1
direction autrement
la victime un homme de 84 ans on tend à
mesure d'appliquer dans ce col a
effectivement des médications 89 que ce
qu'on ferait pas normalement comme parra
musique de soins primaires sur sur un
arrêt cardiaque normal en effet les
ambulanciers paramédicaux en soins
avancés peuvent administrer du
médicament réservé aux médecins ou
infirmières nous on peut donner des
médicaments pour ralentir le rythme
cardiaque ou on peut même donner un choc
synchronisée pour une défibrillation une
cardioversion on peut aussi installer un
pacemaker transcutanée c'est-à-dire un
stimulateur cardiaque temporaire avant
que le patient soit vu à l'hôpital qui
en est possiblement un permanent la
profession existait déjà aux états unis
et ailleurs au canada au québec une
première corps de 15 étudiants viennent
de compléter leur diplôme universitaire
ils travailleront tous chez
urgences-santé
je veux en faire plus pour les patients
étaient déjà à l'aise dans ce que je
faisais comme paramédics de soins piment
dans l'espoir que je l'aimais je sentais
que je pouvais faire plus
urgence compte 950 techniciens
ambulanciers les ambulanciers
paramédicaux en soins avancés forme donc
seulement 2 % de la main-d'oeuvre une
maigre proportion qui pourrait augmenter
avec les années et qui peut surtout
faire toute la différence ici marie
laurence de l'aîné radio canada montréal